bella tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
video sono parigi oggi siamo su un gioco
molto particolare i compagni sa di
steppe fere esiste un gioco che ti fa
una versione del monopoly un po strana
si chiama il gioco della vita tu devi
tirare dei dadi e vivere e raggiungere
un obiettivo
giochiamo che capitoli che lo stiamo
parlando le scopre pedine sono queste tu
devi girare la ruota della vita
il buzzer numero che ti esce in cinque
set 1 gv pienissimo funzionario che mi
sembra giusto allora devi selezionare la
carta vado lì per primo 750.000
finalmente un obiettivo diverso
vediamo cosa possiamo fare allora
scegliamo la carriera all'università
pesa scendiamo fare
l'uni l'universo milano dai tecnicamente
perché poi obiettivo a quello però devo
dire anche inizialmente vediamo se mi
importa buono le pare 24 va bene va bene
raga secondo me questo è buon era stata
l'università non so come mai ce l'ho
vista è l'attività online uguale la mia
vita fantastica deve pagare i soldi il
cpm di youtube è così basso abbiamo
girare tutti è un'app che non mi giravo
che partito dalla società più che
perfetto libero dai chi perde va in base
a rossonero mio più aperti
le ffs ha vinto ne dite io non ho più
soldi ho perso non sono bravo nel mezzo
e 30 mila tra i bavaresi da tutti no no
no andiamo tutti vediamo chi avrà la
carriera migliore università di carriere
si sia ormai questa è quella che fa
discesa mila volta paga di chicago fire
uccidevano incontri di b che bel dipinto
però un'idea bellissima tocca a me
altro grande tipo legalità perché
all'università mamma mia il giro piu
alto diceva 50k scegliere avversario
sempre a braccio senza per e allora vai
mafai dieci minuti icona talmente girato
potente 996
bene bene i soldi che sei povero bari ei
un bel pezzo dai un bel numero 6
ok allora ti su però questa è una gara a
chi si laurea prima per scarone armi sì
mi sono creato allora vai vai verso di
nuovo nella laureata si verrà è
bravissimo grazie e allora adesso decidi
lavoro questo è quello che conta
beccare quello giusto io prendo il
secondo 100k è si può avere molto meglio
centrocampo andava bene dai la faccio un
astronauta almeno la sonata garillo
sibello vela
ok adesso mi serve un bel 10 per
riscattare un botto di soldi
5 mano prova dirlo poi quello che amava
ok però andiamo subito a 180.000 bello
così bello così e qui grande ma cove 70k
grandi l'argine alloggi con astronauti e
vabbè se non sono io ma tanto devo fare
una casella perché anziché mile vogliamo
creare oppure io
scommetti che perché al lavoro da
150mila
lo scopo di queste prendiamo questo
punto 20120 avvocato mamma mia
ma cosa sono le gemme li sa dove avete
fatto voi no a un numero fortunato se tu
fai per numero paghi che la persona
capito ho fatto dieci quando era
laureata e tempo della laurea che lui è
il ritardatario avremmo per cal miliare
a giusto è il piatto ma che schifo anche
il tipo di lavoro dai vertici
almeno questo trend e quando avete soldi
questo è senza soldi di manca sposarsi
si vuole sposare subito risolti dice che
abbia per giro dalla banca madonna non
di vicinato che 16 10 faccio 100k esatto
ovviamente da un pò c8 dai 80.000
abbiamo capito dispositivo è ricchissimo
mamma mi ha commentato cpm cpm di
veterinari altissimo ragazzo che è il
momento in cui io correrò la mia vita e
con gli sposi
gay però schedina la perde va bene ma
accettiamo pezzetti fermare ne va bene
ok imparate il matrimonio lui sta
pensando ad altre gallery sono i soldi
perché adesso è niente se fa il numero
alto ok tuoi per me number alto
devo farlo alto per forza più è alto più
prendisole italy regalo di nostro
aspetto perché pensando 220 perché nato
dove se non lo so va bene ma mi fa anche
di girare migliore ma di nuovo girando
come un uomo dai a queste per muoversi
se ma anche le altre 200 non lo so
magari avrà un marito ricco nono lavoro
ai dati diffusi da prese palma mi fa
risolvano di è una base bene o male
nemmeno male privati si è giocata
attenzione in una giocata solo ancora
giro ma gioco sono io ragazzi di vedersi
grazie partecipato per andare avanti
sono 700 ve ne mancano siquas quanto
molto io non so come vediamo di
recuperare qualcosa
vai e per un astronauta camera
ok allora farina rosa questa volta e
voglio 200.000 anche io ma lo leggo
secondo me tipo in base fa il rossonero
prende 100 o 200 e probabilmente sì
probabile sensi a quello dal bravissimo
memoria in dieci minuti o come
all'estero agli occhi rosa è sì anche al
resto al rosso gira per il regalo di
matrimonio
ti prego una fortuna nella vita grazie
magari 800 mah vabbè se mi toccano
mancavano i soldi
martha capello sono 700 io vado
difensivi che sono spariti di solito dei
soldi festival è un ente bellissimo
rispetti quanto trovate soldi andrea
brigata i soldi non mi è chiaro perché
ogni e pagato il matrimonio tra io sono
pagato misseri è vero è vero che il kata
120 ogni volta prendete facendo solida
il matrimonio però veloce ne abbiamo
visti due di fila ma stava bene per
esperimenti
date le ruote si tiene sempre
dichiarazione brutta ma vuole più marito
quello che la mia era mio prima sicuro
che guy ha detto una volta un regalo di
nozze numero e fa due ragazzi perché non
vai a roma perché davvero il marito di
favi che riccò capisci certo è lui che
mi ha detto che aveva presentato per
quel motivo sono anche gay
tutti in fila va bene già pianto dice le
700 non sceglie la palla ma perché
succede di solito io ho scelto di soldi
di nuovo ma basta
ma per i miei fan ma per noi ma che non
tumori ma perché perché i suoi ricca
ragazzi matrimoni vorrebbe vendere
privilegiata la direzione rifilato tutto
basta levarmi i soldi spilorci 2 ho
fatto che schifo e non ho problemi di
gioco thrower simili si eviterà era lì
ogni cosa vuol dire dove lo stesso lo
stesso giudice capito il momento però
devi raccogliere la rete e schivare un
guasto le cartine no premendo col click
e sinistro destro
allora io sono esperti in giochini
facciamo silenzio capitano un la son
pronto allora io sono quello di sotto
ora mi funziona vedi che prima non mi
piego ok storientando rico 39 a 19 22
120 70 200 perché ieri bilanciati
ribilanciato i soldi non so perchè il
negativo per di più però prodotto in
salita
non so per quale motivo mi avete
veramente raggiunto ormai è in balia del
caso 10 è infatti attenzione
torna in gioco 12 vediamo 45 so il
maghetto na evasi ventre 89 e dvd 1
entrambi seguiti un colpo di karate
girate allora ti rendi conto che se tu
vinci adesso e poi prendi la paghetta
into veramente no veramente vizzino
marinava adesso tu al prossima volta che
tirinto quindi io vinco adesso io ho
vinto tu perché la paga dice lina la
palette l'agente del prossimo lauree io
vado angolo due o tre vinto ho vinto
così sì perché per una casella si
credono una casellina la splendida
partita mi sono emozionato soprattutto
nel momento del matrimonio ragazzi nella
vita l'importante e sposarsi per soldi
rubare i fogli a tuo marito esatto
io mi fate domande con questo che gli
sia piaciuto
iscrivetevi al canale anche gli step e
fare le tratte in descrizione lasciato
un bel mi piace un commento e noi ci
vediamo come sempre ad un prossimi suo
video ragazzi bella tutti
[Musica]